I want two one two three four hi I'm Ted
bellacor with reason TV and today i'll
be speaking with mark frauenfelder
frauen Felder is founder of the hugely
popular blog Boing Boing editor-in-chief
of Make Magazine and author of the new
book made by hand searching for meaning
in a throwaway world all right what do
you what do you got there well this is a
cigar box guitar it's probably my eighth
or ninth one that I've built so far it's
really fun because everyone that you
make sounds different you know for me
anyway because I you know probably make
a lot of mistakes and things but it ends
up each one has kind of its own
personality so it's fun to see what they
end up sounding like yeah and well it's
sort of a microcosm of your book why
don't you tell us a bit about the book
yes sure so made by hand is a book about
my kind of explorations in the
do-it-yourself world and I was always
interested in like DIY media Boing Boing
started as a print scene in the late 80s
and so I was interested in that and you
know things like silk screen t-shirts
and and of course the web and blogs and
all that but I was never really handy
but once I started editing make magazine
I came into contact with all these
people who are really great di wires and
what I learned from them was that they
were all like really okay about making
mistakes in fact I kind of considered
making mistakes part of their creative
process they realized that they were
going to break tools and you know spend
money they didn't need to going on wild
goose chases and stuff but in the end it
was worth it for them because they were
had all this cool stuff that they like
lived with and was part of their lives
so I kind of decided that I wanted to
try that out as a as a way to live and
see if we could make my life better so I
started doing things like you know
building a chicken coop and raising my
own chickens and becoming a beekeeper
making things like cigar box guitars I'm
a big espresso fiend so i retrofitted my
espresso maker to control the
temperature I started carving my own
wooden spoons and you know other kitchen
utensils and things like
and it turned out that was you know it
was really a lot of fun I really enjoyed
your book is sort of soothing that's at
times and inspirational at other times
and one of the things that I think was
on the more inspirational side was you
mentioned it earlier your embrace of
making mistakes but but these days we
kind of live in a zero-tolerance you
know society where we're trying to
minimize risk all the time are you how
does that interact with the DIY culture
yeah and a lot of ways we don't want to
make mistakes yeah I mean you know you
should try not to make mistakes on
purpose of course but you shouldn't also
equate mistakes with failure or punish
yourself about them basically in school
mistakes equal bad grades so that kind
of conditioning you know in the real
world is I don't want to make mistakes
because I'm going to be punished so I'm
going to avoid risk you know and schools
do that by closing down shop classes and
replacing them with you know computer
classes and things like that so just
accept mistakes if something is a you
know a way to learn and get creative and
come up with new ways to do things and I
think that's that's something that our
schools have kind of forgotten about and
it's not like having it the current way
avoids mistakes either right you just
you end up still making this yeah big
mistake yeah it's like at least your way
it's more of a bottom-up discovery
process where you're kind of learned
making mistakes and learning along the
way yeah I think so you know and brain
research has shown that the fastest way
to learn something is by making a
mistake I think it gets really embedded
in your brain when you make a mistake
and you you know don't want to make that
mistake again you go on you know you
raise the bar and and have new
challenges and you know get better at
what you're doing that way you mentioned
the ultimate indie do it yourself
education which is unschooling yeah you
describe it on school yeah well I it you
know I met these people who are like
really smart kind of successful people
usually in like the information
technologies and web industries and they
practice unschooling with their kids
which is not home schooling big you know
where parents take the roles of teachers
and it's it's still you know basically
teaching your
to be a scholar you know sitting there
and learning how to conduct research and
write reports and things like that
unschooling is letting kids you know get
bored at home and get bored with their
friends and come up with their own ways
to learn you know you might point them
in the way of projects or something like
that like you know if the kid expresses
interest in making a kite or something
you know you can help them along the way
and the cool thing about something like
that is if you make a kite you learn
geometry and angles you learn about the
weather you learn about materials you
learn about physics so that kind of
learning is is based on you know
projects creating things and that's a
better way to learn you know like like
I've always had that but you know like
learning computer programming languages
if you just take a course and try to
learn a programming language it's really
hard to memorize something but if you
have a project so you want to you know I
take measurements you know of motor
torque at different speeds or something
you and you have to write a program to
measure that then you will learn that
program that programming language just
because you want to get something
accomplished so you know giving goals
unschooling is big about you know giving
kids goals that they're interested in
doing you know if they want to learn how
to build a robot or or rocketry or you
know build a treehouse or something they
have to learn how to you know they have
to learn a lot in order to get that
thing done even if that means they sit
in from the TV playing video games from
six months right in some of the people
you spoke with said that parents should
be okay with that she actually the kid
is going to get tired of Numidia and
that's what you know they won when that
group a couple that I interviewed for
the book they were worried because their
kid was just you know like playing video
games for six months and like oh my god
are we screwing up with this but
eventually the kid moved on to video
games that had a lot of text and he
didn't know how to read I think he was
like seven or eight at the time he
couldn't read and he said you know what
are they saying what did they sang on
the screen and the parents were like you
have to learn how to read don't you to
figure it out and so he learned to read
and they said it was amazing within a
matter of you know months he was like
his reading level was
it was much higher than than other kids
of his own age just because he had that
drive to you know figure out what was
going on in the book you discuss a
little bit is unschooling even legal
because it's not it's not conventional
schooling it's not even home schooling
as you mentioned yeah yeah they mean
they they have to do little tricks you
know they do have to register as a
homeschool thing xenon and the parents
have to I think provide a curriculum and
things like that so you know they have
to kind of sneak sneak their way past
some of the regulations and things like
that but I think they're becoming more
powerful you know getting together and
then convincing you know school boards
of what they're doing is really pretty
effective and they're showing how
successful on school kids are in the
real world do you think we're becoming
too obsessed with certification and like
you've got to get the right degree and
and then we sort of forget about the
experience side of things yeah I think
so I mean you know you look at people
like you know Bill Gates Steve Jobs
Larry Ellison they all dropped out to
school you know some of the smartest
people I know in the you know in in
journalism and in DIY you know
successful people are either you know
never went to college or even dropped
out of high school because they just had
a passion for you know experiences and
trying things out on their own I am you
know I I would hate to say I don't think
that's for everybody some people
probably should stay in school but if
you have that drive to go out there and
do something you know do it you're going
to learn so much more that way and a lot
more quickly I think that if you just
stay at school and you know just study
what other people are doing